MARKUS KLUTE: Hello.
So in the last video, we
looked at ranges of forces.
So we already saw one
aspect, and wanted
to learn about what
kind of interaction
happens when you study
a specific force.
You learn about
the force carrier
from noting the range in
which forces interact.
In this class, we
talk about decays.
But in more general
terms, when we
want to measure
properties of forces,
we have basically
three concepts at hand
which can be
experimentally determined.
The first one is
masses of bound states.
| you might remember
from atomic physics
that you learn a lot about
electromagnetic interaction
by studying, for example, the
hydrogen atom, where you have
an electron circling
around the program,
and you can study
in detail aspects
of the electromagnetic
interaction.
The second aspect is decay
rates of unstable particles,
or the width of an
unstable particle.
So in quantum mechanics,
the lifetime of the particle
is related to the width.
And so that's what we're going
to discuss in this video.
And then lastly, we can look
at the reaction rates expressed
as cross sections.
So that's the topic of
the next video after this.
Let's talk about decays.
So we can define this new
symbol, the decay rate lambda,
and s as a function
of time, probability
that a particle will survive
at least until some time t.
We can now discuss this,
and say, the probability
at some time t relates to
the probability at some time
t plus delta t by the likelihood
1 minus the decay rate
times the time
interval, delta t.
And so from this, we find that
the change of the probability
for the particle to survive
is proportional to that
probability and decay rate.
So now if we integrate
this, we find
that the log of this probability
is equal to some constant times
lambda decay rate times time.
So now, if you simply assume
that the particle existed
at the initial time t, we
said we set k equal to 0.
We find this very
famous exponential decay
law, e to the power
of minus lambda t.
And this is shown here in this
picture as this exponential.
So far, so good.
We can now define and look at
this distribution a little bit
more.
We can, for example,
look at the average time
for that a particle lives,
because the average time
tau is simply given by the
integral from 0 to infinity.
So we basically integrate
over this distribution
to get the average
time for the particle.
And that's equal to 1 over
the decay rate, 1 over lambda.
You can do the algebra,
yourself, in fact,
to follow this.
So if you now express this
probability for the particle
to survive until some time
t through the lifetime,
you find this is equal
to e to the minus t
over the lifetime
of the particle.
So you might not want
to look at one particle,
but a sum of particles
and look, at the time
dependence of the number of
particles which survived.
Because it's equal to
the number of particles
as a function of time is
equal to the initial number
of particles times
the probability
that any given
particle survives.
And that's, again, given
by this exponential.
In nuclear physics,
one often talks
about the half life, half
life time of the particle
or of [INAUDIBLE].
And that's given,
as you would assume,
by the time it takes for half
of the particles to decay.
So N of tau 1/2 is equal to the
number of initial particles, N0
over 2.
And you find, then,
that this half life
is related to the
lifetime of the particle
with a factor of about 2/3.
This leads to some confusion
in numerical values
sometimes when you ask for
specific answers from up here,
in experiments.
All right, so there's another
aspect of decays which arises,
which comes from a fundamental
property of quantum mechanics.
So if you have an
unstable state,
or any unstable state does
not have exact energy state,
it just follows, if you want,
from the uncertainty principle.
So the width of the
particle is quantized,
and it's quantized
with this lambda here.
And if you can see,
lambda relates, again,
to the decay rate or the
lifetime of the particle.
Another complication
can occur when
there's multiple ways for
the particle to decay.
For example, you
have a Higgs boson
as we see on the
next slide, which
might decay into multiple--
has a way to decay into
multiple particles.
Here, we define a partial
width, where the partial width
is defined as half the
width of the particle
to decay into a specific mode.
And then the total
width of the particle
is given by the sum
of the partial widths
of all possible ways for
the particle to decay.
Using this, you
can also calculate
the likelihood of a particle
to decay in a specific way.
That's called the
"branching fraction."
And that's given by the
partial width divided
by the total width, or the
partial decay weight divided
by the total decay rate.
Again, the total has to
be 1, the probability
for a particle to
decay in any mode is 1.
Therefore, the sum of the
branching ratios is 1 as well.
All right, so looking
at a specific example,
the Higgs boson is probably
my favorite example
in this entire class.
You find here, given
branching fractions or ratios
of specific decay modes,
because it's not always in which
the Higgs boson decay,
but the most dominant one.
The most prominent one is the
one with Higgs boson decays
into a pair of b quarks.
We will later see, maybe
even as an exercise,
why the distribution
function of branching ratios
is the way it's
being shown here.
The Higgs boson has been
measured with a mass
of 125 gV and a little bit.
And you see at this mass
here, the prominent decay mode
is simply the b
bar, but it's also
possible for the exponential to
decay into a pair of W bosons,
where an interesting
loop diagram into gluons.
Even so, gluons are massless,
or tau, charm, Z bosons, and so
on.
And we just showed you in a
paper which was submitted today
to the arXiv, the
Higgs boson also
can decay into a pair of muons
with a branching ratio of 2
times 10 to the minus 4.
So it's rather rare,
but it's possible.